what's up you guys
it's movie retrospective time once again
yeah
here's the one that won this week this
one only won by a vote or two but i'm
actually kind of glad that this one won
because
this is a movie that i watched on
cable a [ __ ] ton of times back in the
early 90s and i hadn't actually seen it
for a while so it was like really cool
to revisit it it's um
it's on hulu i'm sure you can get it
other places too but that's where i
watched it
and that's where i got the idea to put
it in the bowl this is
arachnophobia from 1990. yeah do you
remember what month this came out in
july okay it came out in
like late july of 1990 yeah i think i
saw this in the movie theater
i think i did as well and that would
have been like a couple months before i
joined the army which that kind of
checks out
this was right i'm sure i saw this one
yeah this was the same week
i think this was the same week that
ghost came out
and the same week that uh die hard 2
i want to say because i think this was
the third highest
uh you know highest ranking movie that
week
i remember that there was like a big
fuss about it it was the it was the best
new thing you know at the time
and i'm pretty sure i saw this one in
the theater i know i saw it afterwards
yeah but i think i saw this in the
theater too
and i had forgotten how much of a steven
spielberg
type movie this is well that's because
steven spielberg was a producer on it
and also the director
frank marshall this was actually his
first
full-time you know full directing thing
but prior to this probably better known
as a producer for amblin entertainment
he's also one of the founders of amblin
entertainment stephen k
uh stephen king steven spielberg's
production company uh you know he's
married to kathleen kennedy the three of
them formed
amblin and he had previously worked as a
second unit director
on a bunch of steven spielberg movies
including in the indiana jones movies
and all those ones
so you can tell that they all had kind
of that same aesthetic
you know what i mean they had the same
tone yeah yeah and it's very it's very
early 90s
spielbergian kind of an all-american
kind of tone
to it america poken funded itself at
certain times there's a lot of [ __ ]
wisecracks about
mainstream america in it you know what i
mean rather there was
she said you guys oh so you're a
nepotist he goes nowhere baptist
coming from mississippi i was kind of
laughing yeah
those [ __ ] little baptist towns
they're all related to each other
yeah the way you're going to get a job
is if you're related to somebody in the
damn town
yeah it's a very it's a very small town
type of story
it's and it reminds me a lot and i think
this was um
you know this seemed like this was a
deliberate thing that they wanted to do
was it kind of a throwback to a lot of
the kind of the 50s monster movies a
little bit
and um frank marshall the director like
i said um
he basically wanted to make something
like alfred hitchcock's the birds
yeah although i don't think they
actually did if you asked me
i even made that i even i even confused
this when you first asked me about oh
this is what we have to see i got i got
us confused with the kingdom of the
spiders
with shad with shad yeah and this that's
from 76 i think yeah this one always
reminded even when i
saw it back in the later on vhs you know
what i mean like
in the 90s later on it always kind of
reminded me of a
of a of a high class [ __ ]
kingdom of the spiders kingdom of the
spiders was like it sucked it was like
something
made from tv but it was cool in the day
you had chat running around trying to be
shat in western clothing fighting
spiders it was ridiculous
i mean the thing about kingdom of the
spiders is that it
the the difference between it it's like
yes it's both about spiders
arachnophobia knows what it is it knows
that it's trying to be a comedy like
it's trying to creep you out too but
this is
kind of i don't even i wouldn't even
call this a horror movie really unless
you're really really afraid of spiders
and then it might be upsetting
and you know p a lot of people do die
and [ __ ] like that in it
but it's done in a sort of light-hearted
way this is kind of one of those
kind of like gremlins yeah like 80s 90s
sort of things where
it's kind of like a horror movie but
it's something that a little kid could
watch
without yeah without like upsetting them
too much
so jurassic park type thing you know
what i mean
it's a horror movie in the way that
poltergeist does a horror movie yeah and
it gets lumped in with a lot of
movies like that because like i said
it's got it's got scary parts in it and
people die and terrible things happen
but it also has a bunch of funny [ __ ]
and you know it's
just the tone of it is a lot more
light-hearted so a kid could watch it
and it wouldn't like traumatize them for
life or anything like that so it's kind
of like a good
gateway drug if you're trying to get
your kids into horror you know
i remember not liking this movie back in
the day i'm really just not
being that impressed with it but it's i
like it now better than i did
i think because of this the nostalgia
and it did age pretty well
it was shot pretty well good it had a
good spielbergian [ __ ]
tone to which wasn't a thing back in the
era of spielberg that was just the way a
normal movie was
and realized that there was a spielberg
style
well it's easier to see in hindsight
yeah looking back on it you see it
yeah but you didn't see it at the time
it was just normal that's what you
thought big
big budget movies should be that's how
they should look it's just that that's
kind of like it's kind of like fashion
you know what i mean
it's like it doesn't really seem like
you didn't wear the bell bottles
right when you were watching it but then
like later on you're like what the [ __ ]
is everybody
yeah it's kind of like that yeah but so
okay so arachnophobia it's interesting
because i've watched
a bunch of different people's like uh
takes on this like reviews and stuff
and there was one movie reviewer i can't
remember what his name was but he has a
channel and he's looked real young i'm
not sure how young he was he looked
maybe in his 20s like at the very latest
and he said that arachnophobia was his
favorite spider movie but he said
kingdom of the spiders was a very tight
second
yeah and he was like a really young guy
yeah yeah yeah
about the same well the kingdom of the
spiders takes itself real seriously
which is what makes it funny because
it's kind of campy
whereas this one is you know set out to
be a comedy
yeah the kingdom of the spiders didn't
seem to be campy when you were a kid
well in the late 70s seeing it on reruns
on television you're like oh
man because it was up there with i don't
know kind of like salem's lot when you
were a kid
yeah it was like that but sam's a lot
better though
um there was a lot of nature run among
movies this movie it
it aged well it's it's still a good
movie it has
it's a movie of its time which means
it's going to have some weaknesses
not all the special effects really kind
of held up some of the stuff is
obviously rubber
uh although it's obviously kind of but
some of it's great
it's a weird it's a mixed bag it's
interesting because they didn't
use um they didn't really use any rubber
spiders for this
a couple of the bigger ones were
animatronic yeah but all of the smaller
ones were real they were real but i mean
they wanted to use real spiders there's
something about the way the webs and
then
then the [ __ ] egg casings where the
eggs came out you could tell it was kind
of like a rubber ball and things were
coming out of it just didn't quite
it was it wasn't convincing but
it worked within the tone of the movie
because the movie's not really
trying to take itself too seriously yeah
like i said it's it's a comedy
like everything else yeah it and it just
kind of hits that sweet spot between
being funny but also having like some
horrific [ __ ] happen in it like a little
bit of horrific imagery oh fun fact
speaking of the
special effects some of the animatronic
spiders and this egg sac and everything
you know who worked on that
jamie heinemann from uh mythbusters this
was actually one of his first big
uh blockbuster movies that he worked on
the special effects
i had good humor like little details
like you know
guests at the party stealing food you
know you want a doggy bag for that
and it was kind of uh some of the humor
was kind of
undertones of humor which i thought was
funny which is a good way of doing it
yeah it wasn't alex stuff it's not
really so much in your face yeah it
wasn't like
over the top or zany it was you know the
the humor was like situational
yeah which i think worked a lot better
because it didn't come in your face like
this is funny or anything like that it
was just like
the humor was arising from the
situations um so
what you have is jeff daniels is in this
well first thing you have kind of a
prologue which is set in venezuela and
they did actually shoot it in venezuela
so that is like all real all the jungle
and you know the mesa and everything
like that don't call it a mesa they call
it something else
but um you know so so that's all real
and that was like the first time that a
film had ever been
shot there in that particular area so
they go down there and film it now
julian sands
plays an entomologist it's entomologist
right not etymologist because i know
there's a two different there's one
study of bugs and one study of words
but they're very similar so he's down
there
um they've found like this big sinkhole
and they're trying to
find new species of insects
arachnids whatever so they you know
spray pesticides or whatever and they
catch all these [ __ ] spiders
now it turns out that one of the spiders
that they catch
is uh pretty aggressive and
it ends up killing one of the members of
their crew
who already had a fever um from some he
had like
malaria i don't remember what it was he
had but he had some kind of fever
so he went to lay down and the spider
bit him and he died like almost
immediately but they thought it was the
fever because he'd already
it was already established that he had
that so it so happened that this guy who
was a photographer who was on the team
named jerry manley i think his character
name was
and um the spider that killed him kind
of hitched a ride back to the united
states in that dude's coffin
now it so happened that he lived in a
little fictional town called kanima
california and
so this so the coffin gets there the
spider gets out of the coffin
and you know the coroner doesn't see him
or anything like that but they open the
coffin and the dude's like all he looks
like all his fluids have been drained
out like he looks like a [ __ ] mommy
or some [ __ ]
and they're just like man what the [ __ ]
happened to him they just they don't
know how to preserve bodies in south
america i guess
and that's kind of like the all they
think of it so you have that going on
and then the spider like gets picked up
by a crow and then it bites the crow and
the crow like falls to the earth or
whatever and it ends up in this barn
now then you get jeff daniels like i
said now him and his wife he's a doctor
like a gp
and she's a stockbroker now they're from
san francisco
but i guess they're like well we want to
come out here to the country
and raise our kids you know because san
francisco's too big a city it's too much
crime or whatever
so they move out here to kanaima
california and they buy the house now
they chose this town in particular
because the doctor
that's already in town this old coot
said that he was gonna retire
so jeff daniels um is gonna take over
his practice and only when he gets there
and buys the house and everything
the old fart decides that he's not gonna
retire so jeff daniel's like well [ __ ]
me now like
what am i gonna do now because now i
have like no patience
so as it turns out there's one older
lady in the town
who doesn't really like the old fart
doctor and so she's like well i'll be
your
one patient okay so he has one patient
and he's like
oh yay goody and um but it turns out
that she goes to him and he's like yeah
i don't think you need these
bl you know blood pressure pills or
whatever that the old fart doctor was
giving you so she stops taking them and
then a day or two later she drops dead
so then it kind of establishes even
before you get to the spider stuff
because you know that the spider stuff
is going on in the background because
what ends up happening is that
the spider that came in the coffin from
venezuela
mates with a regular house spider
and the strain that is thus produced is
kind of like this
really really venomous uh type of spider
that also
kind of is more like an ant colony type
of [ __ ] where it has like a queen and
you know
which spiders don't usually do that's
you know it's very unusual but that's
kind of like a plot point that's in this
so it kind of sets up this thing where
um where it's like small town versus big
city because now
even though it's the spiders that are
picking off the citizens of this town
like one by one
it so happens that every time one of
them dies like the doctor has seen them
like
you know the young doctor has seen them
like a day or two before
so everybody's in this small town was
like oh this big city doctor comes here
and all these people start dropping dead
and
like they don't know what to do and so
so there's kind of like something like a
conflict there and he gets starts
getting called dr
death and like the old fart doctor is
gonna [ __ ] sue him and all this other
kind of [ __ ]
but then as it goes on about at the
halfway point of the movie they actually
do figure out
that um it is a spider that's causing
all of this stuff
at which point you know they contact
julian sands from the beginning of the
movie
and you know kind of try and figure out
what the [ __ ] is going on with these
spiders
now okay so the interesting thing about
this like i said
um they used almost all
real spiders in this anytime you see
like spiders going through the walls or
like crawling on people's faces or
there's one like real famous scene where
the spider comes
jumps down on that girl's face like
while she's in the shower and like
slides out her stomach and all of a
sudden
those are all real spiders they had to
have all the uh
the actors kind of they're like hey um
how do you feel about having spiders
crawl all over you because that's what's
gonna happen
i thought this was very funny i was
watching like this really old
documentary about this that came out
like
shortly before the movie came out that
was kind of like the making of and blah
blah blah
and the guy that played jerry manley in
the movie was like hosting it
and he said that what they had to do
he's like because
casting insects or animals in a movie
is just like casting people you know you
have to try out different ones
so what they ended up doing was they had
a spider olympics
like before because they were trying to
determine what the best breed of spider
for the [ __ ] that they wanted the
spiders to do in the movie you know what
i'm saying
so it you know because he's like some of
them you know run too slow or some of
them aren't very good at climbing up
glass or some of them
you know so it's like we had all of
these tasks that we wanted the spider to
do over the course of the movie and then
we had like seven or eight different
species of spiders
um to see which one could do it the best
so which i thought was very cute i was
like i kind of wish that they had filmed
all of that because that would have been
really funny
but i think the one they ended up
picking for like the main spiders was um
i think they're called avondale spiders
they're from new zealand
little yellow ones yeah they're kind of
they kind of look like they're
kind of like a hunting spider a wolf
spider they kind of look like that which
they have those here um that look really
similar yellow with black
feet yeah and um they said well we liked
those because you know they were big
enough that you could like see them and
they looked real creepy
and they were real good at like climbing
up glass and jumping
and and they were kind of fast which
they kind of wanted because they said
that's creepier
and also they're real docile and they
were easy to work with
and um they're completely harmless to
humans
so that was the one they picked now they
also had to have a couple bigger spiders
because
um you know in in the context of the
movie they had one that was a queen and
then they had one that was like a
general
some of those were animatronic but some
of them were not they actually did use
like one of those big
bird eating tarantulas like from south
america
or whatever they actually used one of
those but it was like really interesting
because they had this dude i can't
remember the [ __ ]
what's the dude's name something frank
kutchner i want to say
um i don't remember frank is his first
name but he's kind of like a real famous
like
bug and spider wrangler and he's does
that for like a lot of movies he's doing
for years and years
and they were talking about all the
different ways that they were getting
the spiders like to do
what they wanted them to do in the movie
and like some of the background shots of
like yourself
there's like spiders all over the walls
and they're like putting them in little
bowls and [ __ ] like that and they're
putting like
[ __ ] little tracks of lemon juice or
like
blowing on them with a hair dryer and
[ __ ] like that like to get them to move
around the way they wanted it because
they said you know you can't really
train spiders
you can only manipulate you can only
manipulate them and like try not to hurt
them and i was like
it's weird because i was like kind of
worried about i was like no they didn't
hurt any little spiders
because i kind of like spiders i'm not i
know people are a lot of people are
creeped out by them
but i'm really not i don't like them at
all can't talk really does that movie
didn't really creep me out about
just something about this movie it's
just the tone of the movie it didn't it
didn't give me an arachnophobia feeling
really
i i was indifferent and i think that was
the reason i think
i probably didn't really have really
great memories of the movie
even back in the 90s because you didn't
find it scary no i thought it was just
kind of
it's not it's not a scary movie it's a
fun movie it's a fun
entertaining type of movie which is what
they set out to make they didn't want to
make something that was like horrifying
they just wanted something that was kind
of like ooh kind of creepy but then like
also kind of fun
you know what i'm saying it's kind of
like crosstalking jurassic park and
gremlins yeah it's like a little fun
monster movie now one thing that i did
notice
on this um go-around that i don't think
i noticed the first time because now
that i'm
you know more i guess i'm more um you
know conscious of
different types of cinema techniques and
[ __ ] like that
one thing that they do a lot in this um
that's actually really cool because i
don't think they really do this in a lot
of other monster movies
is that some is that something they
would do a lot
was they would have the actor like say
you know the old lady that
the first one that gets killed in the
town by the spider
and they'll have her like come into the
room and sit down and then the
camera will pull back and then the
spider is like in the lamp so it's like
they always like have a continuous shot
showing the person and then showing the
spider in the same shot as them like
there's no cuts or edits or anything
so that you always know where the person
is and where the spider is but the
person can't see the spider so it's kind
of like this suspenseful
type of [ __ ] because that's what they're
they said they really were
cognizant of alfred hitchcock's thing
where you know where he has like kind of
a famous thing where he talks about
suspense
and he's like you know you and me are
here talking about baseball
and there's a bomb under the table and
you know the bomb goes off
if you do it like that then everybody in
the audience is just like oh they'll be
like startled for a few seconds and then
they'll forget about it
but it's like if you show you know if
you if you show like the two people
talking about baseball the tape and you
show the audience the bomb
under there and said oh it's going to go
off in five minutes then that's what
suspense is you have to give audiences
like certain information
that the people in the movie don't have
in order to generate
suspense so that's kind of what
the um you know kind of the framework
that they were going for with this
because they were always showing
where the spiders were but the people in
the movie didn't
see them and they said that was one of
the best things about
making a creepy movie like this about
spiders is that the spiders they said we
don't want to make like big huge ones
because they've been like a lot of like
giant spider movies and big bug movies
and stuff
but they're like in a way it's kind of
creepier if they're
smaller because they could be anywhere
you know like i said the one dude like
the old fart dude that died the doctor
that dies
the [ __ ] spider like crawls into his
shoe and then bites his toe and then he
has a [ __ ] heart attack and you know
and then there's one in like a cereal
box and
you know they can just be anywhere and
like
pop out at you and then you'd be dead
like in a few seconds
which you know is pretty creepy when you
[ __ ] think about it
but yeah so so that's why but yeah they
said that was that was something they
were really really aware of that whole
alfred hitchcock thing it's like
you know we'll have a kid like bending
down to pick up a baseball
and then there's a spider right there
you know or the kid or the football
player that dies
you know right before he picks his
helmet up the spider climbs in there and
then so
so you know what's gonna happen but the
people in the movie don't know what's
gonna happen that's what they
that's what they said all right but they
probably
it's more likely that they chose little
spiders because it was cheaper
that's probably what it really was
because if you ask me
a whole bunch of spiders living in the
ground in like a nest
or out in the forest in a nest and each
one of them ends up being
the size of an alaskan king crab no i'd
rather see that especially if it was
like believable you know what i mean
imagine if they were you know imagine if
they had legs it was like three and a
half inches in diameter
you know six foot across [ __ ] leg
span
you know where it's not so big to where
it's like 50s monster movie atomic
[ __ ] spider you know the size of a
building not not that big
but big enough to [ __ ] be a threat
but at least you know
you would know where that was at though
they couldn't hide as good
it couldn't hide but they could you know
come into your house
you know like in a swarm you know
like something like david triffids you
know it wouldn't be one of them it'd be
a whole bunch of them
and they'd be kind of like an ant colony
each one of them with a body the size of
a cat or something
big old jaws on it that would freak me
out where there was
where like one or two of them could drag
you off
i'd like to see that i kind of feel like
because there have been a lot of
spider movies we haven't seen like i
said i've seen a bunch of kind of the
50s big bug ones like tarantula and uh
there was one that was just called what
the [ __ ] was that one called i don't
know there was one on mystery science
theater but a camera but that was also
like a big giant tarantula
but there were some more recent ones it
was like um
eight-legged freaks there's a lot of
people now the ones in eight-legged
freaks i feel like that was one
spider that was about as big as a car
but
am i remembering it wrong that there
were some smaller ones that are about
the size that you were describing i
don't know i never seen that one
yeah we watched it together a few years
ago yeah forgot about it i just can't
remember because
i get it confused with because it was
another one that was called big ass
spider
that was a good one that we watched that
was good yeah and
i remember i remember a lot of people
not really like a
uh liking eight-legged freaks although i
remember kind of like
i remember i remember what what you're
talking about now but i don't really
remember the size of the spiders but
that's what i'm saying remember that
movie
yeah i mean it wasn't as good as big-ass
spider
big-ass spider was good because it knew
what it was it was like sharknado
yeah i mean i have to remember i can't
remember like um
which one was which now and so i get
them both confused i'm pretty sure we
saw eight-legged freaks first and it had
the dude from scream in it right yeah i
think so
and then yeah and so like i don't
remember but i could have sworn
that eight-legged freaks had like one
big one and then
a bunch of smaller ones that were like
dog size i thought
but i could be remembering that
completely wrong i could be thinking
the total thing is that if they were to
do what i would describe today they'd
want to do that [ __ ] cg you don't want
you want it practical
well yeah because i look real the cg
spiders and eight legged flames
look terrible like the big ones look
there's got to have some mass
you know it's got to be able to come
after you i think that's why
that's why this that's why arachnophobia
that's probably why they went that way
i like that so much and i think that's
why that's a lot of people's favorite
spider movie is because
all those are real spiders it's not a
bad movie i'm not saying it's a bad
movie
i have a lot of affection for it just
because i mean i saw it a bunch of times
on cable and it's just some
and it's one that has like a lot of
re-watch appeal for me
it's kind of one of those movies that
and this the young guy said this too
he's like this is one of those movies
where every time if you're flipping
through the channels or whatever and you
see that it's on you sit there and watch
it
yeah maybe it's just aged well it's
for me it's better now than it was but
at the time i thought it was a little
bit disappointing i can remember
you know being like it was just okay but
you look at it now it's better than it
was maybe it's because i'm older now so
i'm more appreciative
of it you know i was you know still in
my teens i think in 1990
and uh maybe almost 20 i think i just
turned 20.
yeah i was 18. yeah i think i just
turned 20. and uh
you know what i mean i still wanted to
[ __ ] that you know to be [ __ ] large
scale so my jurassic park
you know although jurassic park was the
next movie that
stephen's that was 93. yeah and things
had to be kind of big you know
i mean like to to to kind of impress me
you know that like the things from
gremlins were pretty big you know
just alien and aliens you know i saw
those you know it's just
that was just kind of the mode that was
why jurassic park was such a
success is that the [ __ ] was big and the
cg still [ __ ] hell holds up pretty
well
yeah i just watched that again recently
and that
cg looks better than [ __ ] that was made
in like the mid-20s
i think i think some of it was practical
too
it was well the close-ups were all
animatronics puppets things like that
look good
i mean that's if that's what you're
gonna do i mean like i said i think the
reason that arachnophobia still looks so
good is because
90 95 of the spiders were real spiders
and you know just in some scenes they
used like animatronic or anything like
that they didn't use anything cheesy
obviously it was 1990 so you didn't
really have
um you know you had cgi obviously
because three years later they did
jurassic park but
they really didn't want to use that
because they wanted they wanted the
spiders to stand up and they thought it
would be creepier if the spiders were
real
so that people could react to them
obviously all right you know i just
remember
seeing the movie thinking it was okay
that it wasn't great it didn't really
impress me that much it was okay
and then i remember this movie being
quickly forgotten
and replaced by other movies that were
coming out at the time
i mean it wasn't forgotten as if it was
like a bad movie it was just like it was
forgotten
because it wasn't that memorable like
rewatching this movie again i didn't
remember anything except the bug hunter
who's at the place john goodman yeah
john goodman showed up and i remembered
that character instantly and he was kind
of like the highlight of the movie he
kind of steals the show
remembers some of the things that he had
said and i was like
and i also remember that he was like the
best part of the movie um
he well i think that the i liked a lot
of the characters in this i liked that
um
that [ __ ] [ __ ] sheriff played by
stuart pankin he was hilarious
um the the [ __ ] coroner dude irv
whatever and he's like
he i love that they have that trope they
have this in so many movies
where the coroner like always comes into
the
the morgue or whatever like eating a
sandwich like you know
they're always like eating um and the
the one
the guy i guess that was the same guy
and his wife like watching wheel of
fortune with the popcorn
with the [ __ ] spider runners so
there's like a lot of really good like
characters in this which i think is some
another thing that
i remember just a few months later being
in the army and having guys [ __ ]
quote that [ __ ] john goodman
bughead hunter character and doing that
character
you know in in in the army setting yeah
he's that's a very
iconic he was like the the most
memorable
thing from this movie uh you know
looking back on it
that's what everybody remembered yeah
not so much the spiders or anything
yeah i definitely do think that i mean
and it's funny some of the [ __ ] that he
says because i know that like a lot of
people
you know are talking about the you know
the [ __ ] that he says like yeah i'm bad
and like you know [ __ ] rock and roll
and all that kind of stuff
but for some reason the funniest part to
me is when he's
in the basement of the doctor's house
like talking to the doctor's wife
and he just like casually says would
anyone object if i
tore out this entire floor here and then
she's like i would and he's like
never mind mentioning he's just like
he's just just like little [ __ ] like
that
like find a crack kind of cracked me up
so yeah that was like a really good
character because he was so
you know yeah just like the funny [ __ ]
like when he first met the
the entomologist like the scientist he's
like always nice to meet a colleague you
know i mean he's like an exterminator
and he's like you know what i mean
so it's just like just little lines like
that i think are like really funny but
yeah that's definitely a highlight of
the movie but like i said everybody's
good in this
jeff daniels is good in this um it's
just like a good ensemble cast like the
the characters are all kind of like
distinct
and they all kind of and it's funny
without being over the top
goofy or like you know too much in your
face with it
um but yeah definitely it's on hulu if
you
uh want to watch it if you haven't
perhaps seen it in a long time
um it's it's just funny to me that
you're you weren't creeped out by the
spiders no not really if you
if you because
yeah if you like jurassic park you'd
probably like it if you liked gram and
gremlins you'd probably like it yeah
just kind of a fun
creature feature yeah it's not real
serious almost kind of
like almost what was what was the one
with the damn
monsters that were underneath the ground
the the graboids
tremors almost a little bit like tremors
kind of yeah there's something about it
it occupies that same space
like i said that i think gremlins sort
of established
poltergeist is like that too although
poltergeist is not is funny it had like
comedic moments in it i guess
but it's kind of just kind of that fun
like tremors one
family friendly kind of it's sort of a
horror movie it's sort of scary parts in
it
but you know maybe who framed roger
rabbit like that kind of tone to it
where it has like horrific imagery
but it's the spiders yeah but it's still
real funny and you can still watch it
with your kids and you know they won't
get too upset about it but it's still
like kind of exciting for them to watch
and [ __ ] like that
so as i said if you you know if you're a
parent and you're looking for
movies to get your kid into horror
because i know you know since i
know a lot of people that are into
horror and they have kids and they're
like what's a good
what's a good first horror movie for
kids like to kind of ease them into it
so it doesn't freak them out too much
but this is definitely one that you know
probably should be added to the rotation
along with gremlins beetlejuice all that
kind of stuff that are
kind of scary but they're still
fun and like you know kind of family
friendly for everybody but yeah it's
like i said it's on hulu at the moment
probably
you can probably run it on amazon prime
too i imagine but uh yeah go check it
out if you haven't seen it
and that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we will see you on the
next one
bye